c'est en fait ça fait ça fait un mois et
un gros cyclone qui arrivés aux comores
qui a un peu dévasté un peu tout sur son
passage
surtout certaines écoles et ça fait
depuis un mois les enfants ne vont plus
à l'école avec du coup j'ai eu aussi
mais aussi associé avec l'unicef pour
essayer de de créer une grosse cagnotte
pour pouvoir réhabiliter ces écoles il
faut que ces enfants rentrent très vite
à l'école parce que je trouve que le
plus important c'est l'éducation et aux
je pense que surtout dans des pays aussi
pauvre
l'éducation c'est quelque chose dans ces
importantes primordial donc c'est pour
ça qu'on a lancé depuis deux semaines
c'est un beau la teneur exacte de
réhabiliter les écoles alors c'est pour
améliorer les infrastructures médicales
et scolaires aux comores la fondation
donc soprano et j'ai envie de montréal
et vision un petit défi aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous sommes le 3 juin et
c'est la journée mondiale pour le vélo
donc je vais demander à sopra et doc
gynéco de venir avec moi sur scène
ghanem
[Applaudissements]
j'ai prévu seagate
il
et se régaler
c'est
les séries c'est très simple on a ici un
vélo d'appartement
on va demander à doc gynéco soprano et
moi-même de pédalier on va jouer à
pédales et c'est gagné on va pédaler
chacun 30 secondes ok si en une minute
trente ont fait plus de 1 km on rassure
on aidera l'association quoi qu'il
arrive
mais voilà on sera très content encore
plus d'aider l'association doc gynéco tu
seras don valley on va des sopranos
démarrer si tu seras le deuxième a
pédalé sur quoique sur toi fais le
ramadan je fais maintenant ça va être
très dur
ah c'est vrai alors on va tenir c'est
pour la bonne cause alors attention que
sopra tu peux monter après ce sera trop
haddock et je finirai alors aux trente
secondes
il faut faire plus d'un kilomètre c'est
pas évident j'en dis donc c'est moins
d'une minute trente ans fête ses 30 ans
et il faut faire un kilomètre 30
secondes 30 secondes et en plus on
haddock et 30 secondes
non mais il est illettré sportif en vrai
attention ah bon 3 2 1
[Applaudissements]
oui je viens vous dire 'attendez
radicaux qu'il a bola
ses potes
vous allez dans les conditions
conditions
d'accord
ta peau sopra les mecs on est très mal
arrêté ait arrêté mouaz cette merde mais
celle là on est très mal
sopra pour l'instant pas fait sans même
vous en donner j'étais déconcentré
oui c'est vrai le 3-0 on a encore une
minute donc 32 ans n'est pas une seconde
pour faire 900 m mais autant dire qu'on
n'est pas au top
attention c'est parti fin 2010
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
haha
[Musique]
m'adapte au top
alors elle et l'a fait 300 m merci merci
à ces faux pas est fait pour toi je
pratique c'est que je t'ai non plus sur
une question que dennis byron adu
matières et formes c'est pour faire il
faut faire 600 m way a tenté de braquer
famille le bilan des déplacements je
suis pas michel drucker déplacement sur
bat mais même celle déjà tant que ce
soit 30 secondes comme ça je veux savoir
exactement ça sur top
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec
707 ça n'est pas bien des matches et
puis s'en va falloir 3 22e change une
deuxième chance si j'étais perturbé au
début parce que nous fait défaut
[Applaudissements]
attention abbas en vous une heure c'est
la dernière chance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
la vidéo